talking about collaborative causal
discovery with atomic interventions the
time is all yours uh thank you chris um
i want to thank the organizers leonard
and raghu for inviting me um
my name is uh shivakashushnathan
the title of the talk is collaborative
causal discovery with atomic
interventions and
this jogging to work with raga who's
also an audience and also on the job
market so if you have any positions
contact him
um i guess the the main the main part of
this talk is introduce a new model for
causal discovery where where we want to
learn multiple causal graphs together
and
and i think motivating the model is
going to be the main part of this talk
okay so let me start with the basic
problem of causal discovery where we
have a set of variables and we want to
understand the causal relationships that
between these variables right so we have
some sort of five variables in this
graph and then we want to understand
which variables is causing which right
and the cost effect relationship between
these variables so that's the basic
problem of causal discovery but i think
that the question that we started with
started is there like uh is there one
universal cost figure out right i mean
in multiple scenarios that's not the
case right so in so in many practical
examples if you take there is no really
one universal causal graph that
describes your entire relationship
between the variables the cost of graphs
itself would change over could change
over time could change within people
could change between um populations and
so on right and and this is true if you
look at sciences there are a lot of
publications which explain this
phenomena where they explain that there
is not really one underlying causal
graph but there is really multiple
causal graphs and and and in this case
i'm going to define a causal graph which
also has latents so the the the
variables could be the same they uh that
but the latents could also be different
right for example this is
the paper that we took from
on in epidemiology about the talking
about the uh incidence of diabetes which
is a target variable so they were they
explained about like different
latent variables that could come i mean
uh and the latent variables could have
different influences right so the cost
of graph defined on the observable plus
the latence could be different on for
different set of populations
right so sub population one would have a
causal graph
where economic status is influencing
available physical activity and diet
maybe there is a culture of of of
drinking more alcohol
and that could have an incidence on that
could have an effect on those and
because of genetic reasons
and there could be some combination of
these also
so
i mean i guess in causal discovery we
already have a heart problem we we've
been
they've been lots of exciting work in
the last uh decade or so but about in
causal discovery uh with intervention
design without intervention design but i
think we try to learn something
something i aim something higher here
where we say that how about we learn all
these causal graphs right instead of
learning one causal graph can we learn
all of them together
okay can we use some kind of structural
assumptions or collaboration between
these these different entities that are
there to make the problem somewhat
easier
a quick clarification question just uh
since you referred to the subpopulations
is there a difference between this setup
and just thinking this is a mixture
of different graphs i mean that's one
way of modeling it i mean this this
would be a
slightly different way of calling it i
mean that's another line of modelling
which we should take as that's a mixture
of these sub populations and learning
them yes also clarification
but the graphs are the same that
although the observables are going to be
the same but the legions aren't going to
be the same okay so we're going to we're
thinking of like the a modeling question
whether they are the same set of
observables across different different
entities or population but they're going
to be on the latents could be different
right so the overall graph is not going
to be the same but the graph the set of
observables are the same
i guess maybe one more clarification are
we assuming that there's like in all
three of these subpopulations there's
the three latent variables but in the
first one culture and genes don't have
any effect
but but yes no there's no really
absorption of that they could be they
could they could they could be yeah i
just put an example there
okay so so again so let me just again
rephrase what we've been saying so far
so we have to say n entities and
entities could be individuals when we're
thinking of like individual experiments
or collection of individuals and each of
them we believe has their own causal
graph which could be same or be
different i mean there's no reason them
to be different but they could also be
the same but they could be different too
right i mean again this notion of
entities something like in other
contexts could be businesses or medical
agencies who want to collaborate to
learn something together right i mean
they could be like companies who are
working together to to learn to better
understand their process
or it could be medical agencies who
could be collaborating with each other
hospitals for example and each of them
might they have their own cost of graphs
which could again be same or different
we're not going to say anything about
that for now but uh but we could say
that they have uh n causal graphs and
the goal is to learn them all together
right okay
so yeah so the goal is that to learn all
these costs and graphs of these entities
assuming access to their individual data
so so that i guess the main another
definition of entity is important here
so we are going to say that any entities
on the same set of observable answering
federal expression and basically and
maybe also this each of them generates
their own data right so entities in the
is a
population or a hospital or a business
who's generating their own data right
and so that we can have access to their
data and we can do things with that data
like do experiments or get observational
data
okay so now just a
two-minute detour this might be
not be useful useful for this uh
audience but but let let me just
understand how so we're on the same page
how do we learn a causal graph and this
is the standard
question in causal discovery is that
like the first observation is that like
the observational data itself is not
sufficient because you can't learn
exactly the causal relationship you can
only learn within a markov equivalence
class um
and and if you want to distinguish more
within an equivalence class you need to
do something more and again the know the
notion of interventions or experiments
coming to the picture at that point like
you do interventions or experiments that
that helps you distinguish uh within the
market equivalence class
okay right for example on this case you
can you can do an experiment or
intervention on um and in this case i'm
going to talk about do interventions um
introduced by pearl
and
so basically let's say if you're
intervening on a variable called say
diet so you can fix a diet to a low or
high value and do it your
randomized experiments or something and
then you can understand the effect of
that
and that can be used for using for
causal discovery right i mean so you
make some more assumptions like
faithfulness and then you can go from
interventions to back to the graph
so basically the effect of an
intervention is that all the incoming
edges onto the variable disappears and
this is the graphically what happens
when you do intervention on a variable
okay so
so there is a lot of inaccess there's a
lot of recent exciting work into this
area of how to do efficient intervention
design for causal discovery um but
much of this work has been focused on
this uh this large intervention set
right i mean they think i i think in a
way this is somewhat necessary like
there's no way to avoid it in fact we
have a recent result which shows that
um if if you have latents then you need
at least an intervention set that is
linear in the size of the variables so
there is no way to avoid that if you
have latents in the system
so in a way that's unavoidable so if you
want to discover the causal graph
exactly you need a large intervention
set
okay so but the problem is that these in
practice the large interventions are
infeasible right so like imagine that
you want to do intervention on three
variables together uh physical activity
i'll call diet i mean that may not be
that might be hard for somebody to do it
right i mean it's just a hard design
experiment to construct when you
intervene on multiple variables together
okay so in this work we kind of said
okay so basically what can we do right i
mean so we we we need big interventions
a black set of independent interventions
but we can't do it in practice so in
this talk i'm going to just focus on
atomic interventions which is basically
intervening on a single variable
okay so you're going to intervene but
you're going to intervene on a single
variable at a time
okay so then
as i said the learning the exact causal
tag is not possible in this i mean there
are lower bounds that rule this out so
so the question is what else can we do
right so i mean we can't learn the
excite causal bag i mean so maybe some
other structure can be learned
and in fact there is a nice structure
that comes in that's already been there
in the in the literature for a while are
called maximal ancestral graphs which um
which can be learned using single
variable interventions and
um
so i mean adjust the interaction in max
max are types of causal graphs which
which encode higher order relationships
so they encode like ancestral
relationships that's the name ancestral
graphs coming from
um and they also encode the presence of
latents like i mean there are there are
not only direct digest now but there is
something called as bi-directed digest
and that is used in code uh latents
yeah and uh it's not hard but we show
that we can recover max using just
single variable interventions
okay so then
i'm not going to explain how to
construct a dag from a mac but but uh
but for what i'm going to say is that
like i'm just going to explain what the
meaning of edges in the
mag is so that we are on this
so basically we have the directed digits
which are like the standard directed
edges but now they have a slightly
different meaning so the a an a in edge
from a to b doesn't mean that a is the
pattern of b it just means that a is
answers for b and b is not ancestor of a
uh i mean and that doesn't rule out the
possible of latent confounding between a
and b
um and by derivative h basically means
that a is not answers for b and b is not
ancestor of a and a and b are confounded
so it's kind of a representation you can
think of a graph where you have
observables and latents and now you're
constructing a graph only on observables
but without with but but you're adding
these kind of
directed and bi-directed edges
and there is there is a nice
construction that every dag with latency
can be transferred into unique mag with
observed variables
there's a there's easy construction to
do that
and again if you do if you don't want to
think of max i mean you can think about
you can think of a situation without
latents and then under causal
sufficiency max and dax are the same so
so only in the presence of latency would
they do for otherwise here just to see
[Music]
um
okay so then this is a long line of work
and just interestingly max and many of
many many people in this program
have contributed those work so i mean
uh so i just wanted to give some like a
brief overview of what mags were and
like it was introduced by richard cena
splits in 2002
um and this is like there is at most one
edge between a pair of vertices the uh
the edge could be directed or
bi-directed
right and um
so one of the nice properties that it's
close under marginalization and
conditioning and um
which uh normal tags don't right um so
basically what it means is that like
uh if you take a distribution and that
is uh faithful for a tag
and if i do marginalize on some
variables the resulting
uh distribution may not be representing
any tag
so that's
no no so that's for the dax that's not
happening for max that will always
happen right so if you do marginalize
over the distributions or condition over
the distributions you are still getting
in the mag world
so that that's a nice property that mags
have which dax don't have
and i think that there is also this nice
literature on causal reasoning what you
can do with these maps and you can do
there is a notion of do calculus
extended to these maps there are notions
of d separation which are extended to m
separation and this entire literature on
work on like explaining how uh how these
things
work and in this case like the barcode
equivalence class is called partial
ancestor graph and like if if you are
known about like you might have known
about this algorithm called fci uh which
is a very popular algorithm in causal
discovery and it actually what it does
is that it it actually generates a
partial ancestor graph from observation
later
so if you run fci if you've seen fci
that's basically what it's doing it's
generating a partial ancestor graph
okay
okay so so i guess uh so the revised
goal that we're going to focus now is
that we are going to learn banks okay so
we are not going to learn the causal
tags which are impossible with atomic
interventions we are going to assume
that uh can we learn the max can we
learn the max of the entities assuming
access to individual data
and the natural objective thing is that
like now we have interventions we want
to minimize the number of interventions
right so you have entities that are
doing interventions you want to minimize
the maximum number of intervention any
entities
so any questions so far
yes
from observational data which related to
lots of decks i mean from given one
match it can make including yes yeah so
the mapping from the that magazine the
micro diagonal right so a lot of a lot
of uh yeah
you consider a unique knife from the bag
but the other way is
okay so i guess the the the key
punchline in this in this work is that
if you have entities and if they can
somehow collaborate
the problem actually becomes much easier
that's kind of the main takeaway that
we're going to explore and how do we
formally show this is that we assume
that some kind of underlying
structure or the clustering of these
entities based on their max so because
i'm going to define a natural notion of
clustering which comes in like if you
worked in theoretical series like these
notions of clustering comes quite often
in a lot of different areas but but but
like for this let me let me explain what
this clustering is here for example what
we're going to assume is that the
entities have some clustering so this is
a clustering of these entities so there
are in entities i'm going to cluster
them this this underlying clustering
which is unknown for us but we assumed
that there
okay so basically the idea is that any
two entities belonging to different
clusters have
their max are some far apart and any two
entities in the same cluster have closed
by marks okay so that i have to define
what a close by and far apart means but
this is the rough idea right so we
assume that there is some ground truth
clustering in the universe that that's
that these entities satisfy and so that
they within the cluster the distances
are small and across cluster of the
distance
okay so
so let me let me be a little bit more
formal with this model and so let's say
there might denote the mag associated
with ntdi and let's say n is the number
of variables we're going to define a
distance between two max as the number
of nodes with different neighborhoods so
so we're going to assume that like the
difference between two max the distance
between two max is the number of nodes
uh on which they have different
neighborhood right
so for example in this case i'm just a
very simple example so basically i have
uh these two max are same except for
this bi-directed edge so they differ in
the neighborhoods of a and c would
change
between mi and mj so the distance is
basically two
so i'm just measuring the number of
nodes with different neighborhoods and
that's my distance between the max
again one could think of other notions
of distances and um
but this is the notion that we work with
yes a silly question but does this
define like an actual
instrument okay
awesome
yeah so now from
there one we have a different social now
we can be more formal in defining what
is far away and uh closer so so i'm
going to say that uh the max m1 to m1
are belonging in entity and there exists
the clustering uh a ground truth
clustering c1 start to ck star and these
entities satisfy alpha beta clustering
if any entities in the same cluster have
distance at most beta apart and if you
have two entities in a different cluster
they're at least not finite part so
there is a separation between
entities within the same cluster and
different clusters so if they're in same
cluster there are some just they're
close by and entities within
uh between across clusters so far what
is little n here
the n is the number of variables in the
observable variables
no there's no restriction on k in
general so basically this is not um
any set of max given any set of max i
can have an alpha beta which is
satisfied so that's not so this is not a
restriction on the model it's the same
thing i mean we ideally would like to
think of alpha as well as constants and
then practice right i mean that would be
the nice case because our results might
change with alpha betas but but this
like this will capture all the lines
right we can just say alpha
you know
okay so
so we can always put an entity different
cluster
okay so let me just quickly say that
so let's say here we have four uh seven
entities um and so what so these these
are this would be a max with uh alpha
point seven five and beta point five so
let me just quickly show one example so
for example if you take two any two max
you can see that they only differ in two
nodes in this case a and d so that's
uh beta is uh two there are two there
are different two neighborhoods so and
and the number of nodes is four so beta
is 2.5 and like if you take
any two entities which are in different
cluster they're different at least three
nodes neighborhoods so a acd so the
alpha is uh three by four which is 0.75
okay so so these clusterings can be yeah
so for any sum there exists an alpha
beta value so that any set of max would
satisfy this
uh this notion
okay so now let me quickly go to the
result so what we show is that
um
if you make these uh if you're under
these assumptions of this model being
there x is an alpha beta value so that
your entity is yourself with clustering
um what we show is that we have
algorithms that would that that now
depend on alpha and beta um so just to
give a baseline so if you if you if
entities don't collaborate but they
learn independently of each other then
it's uh we can like it's
you can learn with n uh atomic
interventions but you also need an
anatomical dimensions we show a low bond
there too showing that if you don't
collaborate if if each of them operates
independently you need at least 10
atomic interventions to learn and back
uh so there's uh that's that's the when
you do it don't do collaborate but but
if you if you have if entities can't uh
share some information across them
uh then you can reduce the up like these
bounds to something that that that not
only depend on alpha and beta and and
and
log with dependence on n and k
and uh we also have our lower bounds
which which shows
like at least in some regimes these like
this one by alpha dependence is
unavoidable right
so there is no algorithms which would
which would be able to launch these
without these many dimensions
okay so that that's kind of the rough
idea and then delta is the maximum
degree
across all the maps
so there are stronger results under
alpha zero so beta when beta is
uh beta is zero so when beta0 means that
all the entities in the same cluster
have the same max that that's the that
is basically the beta0 case uh that yeah
so there are stronger results when you
have beta equal to zero
right so
yeah so that's then when i beat a zero
the each cluster is representing the
same act
okay so basically let me quickly give an
overview of an approach um
so yeah so all the algorithms work in
two stages i'm i mean this kind of the
natural way one would think about these
problems if you know these modeling
if you assume these models for example
the phase one is to recover the cluster
memberships right i mean so we assume
there is a ground truth clustering which
we don't know but uh the first phase
would be to recover these cluster
memberships and and then we use these
cluster memberships and
and from clusters we go to the max
okay so
i think the idea is quite simple
actually once you think about a little
bit um so what we do is we sample a set
of uh set of observable nodes and
interviewing on them
for each of the entities so we are going
to take us some set of nodes that we can
we ask everybody to intervene on there
um and that would construct a partial
mag on each of these entities so these
are
these are not really the mags
but these are not really the packs it's
something in between because now we're
doing done some interventions so we know
some some edges correctly but many other
just we still don't know
and we're you're going to use that to
recover the clusters
uh using these partial neighborhood
information
and then we are going to take now once
we recover the clusters what we the idea
is to somehow load balance
the interventions across everybody in
the
cluster
so you first recover the clusters and
now you have the clusters now what you
can do is okay now have like these
entities i know they are all somehow
related so i can somehow load balance
and from that i learned
the max
okay so that's kind of the so let me
just let's explain quickly and
uh so yeah so we have a set of variables
that you want to so you can start with
like partial answers or graphs which
which we know we how to obtain for using
an fci or some other algorithm so let's
say that that's given i mean we don't
need that but we can start from there
and so we we sample a set of random
nodes and um and we just
intervene on nodes on those nodes and
all their neighbors
so so this is assuming that you
intervene on nodes and their neighbors
okay so what we construct is a partial
mac so again this is something that's in
between a pack and a mag because it's
not the it is it has more information
than a pack but it doesn't it's not the
true mag
okay so the idea is that like
this is a really simple observation to
make that if you have an undirected edge
and if you intervene on a so you have
two kinds of things that could learn
from if a is uh dependent on b and the
intervention then you can you can show
that this is a the the direction of it
just has to be like this but if a is
independent of b and a d of a you
actually need to do one more test
but you also have to intervene on b and
that's tha and if that is also
independent then you can say
is uh a and b are by directed edge so
that's why i guess like maybe that's why
we don't really have to intervene on s
we also have to intervene on their
neighbors
that's why we don't intervene on s alone
we also intervene on the neighbors of us
so we have to learn we have to
this test request intervening on both a
and b
when you have independence
okay and
again i guess the idea is that once you
once you construct these partial
neighborhoods we just do a natural
clustering on them and then we show that
that's that um
like i mean i'm just going to talk about
alpha zero clustering but it also
happens in the alpha beta case uh that
with high probability you can recover
these clusters so so these are multi
color algorithms that means that like
the assumptions that like we are going
to succeed with high probability right i
mean with high probability i'm going to
get the true clustering back
um probabilities over the sampling
probably sold something yeah
they're probably the same that's the
only probability there's no assumptions
on the mac
okay and now i guess there are there is
there's a more complicated way i mean
like in this case what i did was
intervene on s and all the neighbors and
s so that will give me a
that depends on the now then like the
maximum degree if you look at this but
there is a more complicated way of of
removing this dependence on this this
max degree and which which is a more
complicated algorithm and these ideas
also extend to alphabetical string like
where uh where what happens is that
within the cluster the mags are not the
same
there's already some variation between
the uh max within the symbol single
even
okay so so
that's what i'm going to say about the
upper bounds how many minutes there
uh you have um
um
degree um
so the maximum degree is of the mag
yeah
yeah so basically you look at the
skeletons among all the maximum
um
yeah it's a great question i think like
i mean obviously like with the latency
it could be arbitrary
because
it can be lower
it can roll right if it's a long chain
there could be edges that go all the way
yeah it could blow up yeah so this is in
terms of max the maximum degree of the
mag but
right yeah i mean if the goal is like
yeah i mean just in this case i guess we
are thinking of only about max and
everything is happening in the mag world
but if you're thinking in the dag world
you probably wanted some kind of some
some restriction on the bags that would
make sure the maximum degree of the max
is not high
and that would lead to that but we have
an algorithm then
that doesn't depend on maximum degree
but you're right
these lower bounds as you mentioned
they should also depend on the degree of
the latents right if that's bounded then
you probably only need like
bounded interventions there's probably a
more refined uh version which would like
i mean i guess these robots are going to
just say about like in the in the max i
mean how many interventions assuming the
uh clustering is the original ones when
you said uh it was impossible
yes so those were once yeah yeah so
there is no there is no restriction on
the on the latent yes but yeah you're
right like if you assume there are there
could be only like
like uh say k-8 and then there's a bound
that would have been created
yeah yeah exactly right right so
actually now it's number of later that
matter like we are like those low bonds
also hold when each each laden is only
affecting two variables so it's a
similar coding case but its number of
latents would play if you assume that
only case that a
pair of variables would be affected by
the latents then then the low bond would
be much deeper and remind me again of
the significance of like atomic
intervention
i think
they come in practice like i mean i
think that's that's one of the main
motivation because in in in like in
practice you can't do interventions now
lots of variables because
uh
i mean
there's one reason that it's impossible
to design an experiment
the second reason is also like when you
do these kind of conditioning dependence
just then you're like like let's see
when you say your k variables you're
deleting one together your domain size
is not going to the power of k even if
the variables are battery so you can do
doing every pair of like two to the
power k like you're setting a variable
yes zero one zero and so on
so
multiple reasons why
to avoid
okay yeah so yeah i think uh so just
what about low boss i think maybe that's
that's interesting i mean um so
basically um
yeah in this case again we are only
leaving the man so we're going to talk
about this
and
maybe there's some translation to the
tag world but that's not done here um so
what we do is we we consider the
distribution over these maps and and
show that um
every deterministic algorithm so would
require omega 1 by alpha interventions
and
and and then there is this favorite
famous uh theorem uh bajao which which
talks about how to take
uh
average case guarantees on the domestic
algorithms and translating the worst
case guarantees on on randomized
algorithms and that basically would be
used just use that directly
and that would give us this lower bound
which says that any randomized algorithm
uh would not be able to succeed uh
without at least omega one by
interventions
so basically this is the hard work and
this this just follows directly from the
ouster
so basically what we're saying is that
like no matter what algorithm you design
if if you want to succeed
with any reasonable amount of reasonable
probability where reasonable this means
like like say three-fourth
you would you would need
you would need at least these many
interventions
so and yeah and um
any questions though sorry
which is your algorithm also
yeah i mean i think that the the idea is
actually kind of natural right once you
once you know what happens within the
clusters then you can kind of know even
how to balance the road right you know
they are somewhat similar like you can
say okay how to design now these
interventions so that they are going to
be somewhat balanced right the goal is
to minimize the maximum number of
intervention right so so it's best to
spread them across everybody right and
and then learn the information and then
share it right
that's the next idea
okay so yeah i guess um
i mean we also ran this in experiments
and like um and like
like i guess these are just for cluster
memberships but what we show is that
like
like even in practice like we we need
like like you can reduce number of
interventions as i said a trivial bound
is uh the number of variables but uh we
can do much smaller than that like at
least half like these are small data
sets uh like small set of variables but
even there we go like we're saying that
like with like even five variables we
can get like the x add mac recovery
under this uh
alpha clustering
okay so let me just conclude i'm running
out of time so i think the main
contribution is that we introduce in our
new castle discovery model to capture
practical scenarios which includes
multiple causal graphs so so in we
believe that that's what happens in in
practice right there is no really one
causal graph that explains everything
that's really a set of causal graphs and
that's what when we want to learn all of
them somehow
and basically we say show that under
some natural clustering assumptions we
show that we can learn with a few number
of interventions then
learning them individually
and um
yeah i guess uh i'm going to let's talk
about uh yeah so one of the open
directions is that like these algorithms
are non-adaptive so basically having
some kind of um
uh sorry these algorithms are active so
that we want non-additive algorithms
that can be run in parallel so basically
what happens is that like if you want to
do if you have non-adapt like uh
non-have algorithms you can run them in
parallel otherwise you have to run them
one after the other because you can't
take your weight from an intervention to
finish before you start the intervention
you're going to end your amount of time
so yeah
happy to take any questions thank you
and if there are any uh let's have like
one question uh here and then we'll be
on break
uh any questions
yes
i'm just wondering about the
non-collaborative setting so imagine you
have basically the exact same setup but
the agents say they're like businesses
they're not going to share data with
each other is there anything that can be
said in that setting yeah i mean i guess
not i mean um
i mean in in this case we don't share it
don't share data right i mean we are not
pulling the data like we each of them
does interventions and they're just
sharing the the
the graphical information right you're
only sharing that like we're not sharing
them together we're not pulling the data
so we're only sharing the fact that yeah
in your case yeah a is passing b but
maybe that's true for me too right
because there's a reason to believe that
we are safe
maybe that's okay to share again but if
you can't even share that then i'm not
sure
great let's think of shh
[Applause]
we'll be back